a second vaccine a second chance of
bringing the pandemic to an end
the american biotech company moderna
says its jab has proved almost
95 effective in preventing covid19
even better than the 90 protection from
the vaccine made by pfizer
the government has only now joined the
scramble for doses buying enough for two
and a half
million people the modern vaccine was
always one of the
front runners why wasn't it part of the
uk stockpile
from the very start why join the queue
now
when you've only managed to cure enough
to protect two and a half
million people the thing is uh thomas
there isn't a stockpile
this vaccine hasn't yet been uh
manufactured
um and here in europe the first
availability will be in the
spring um and that means that uh
obviously we've been
it's critical that we've been buying the
first vaccines that will be available
modernist vaccine like pfizers is based
on rna
the genetic material from the virus but
moderna has stabilized the rna
so it remains active without the -75
temperature that complicates
distribution of the pfizer jab
we do have vaccines that are going to
allow us to at least protect those at
highest risk
and hopefully protect all of us from
cover 19 and that those vaccines are
are not years away um they're not even
you know quarters away they're
they're weeks to months away the more
vaccines we have that work the more
vaccine manufacturers can get into the
game and start producing vaccines the
more widely we can disperse
manufacturing around the globe the
better
and one of the good things although it's
early days is these rna vaccines seem to
be relatively easy to make
moderna will now apply for emergency use
authorization in the u.s
and it hopes to produce enough vaccine
to protect at least 250 million people
next year
but some scientists are still cautious
we see very little effect from tier one
and i think when we look at what tiers
may be there in the future
we will have to think about
strengthening them in order to
get us through the winter months until
the vaccine's available
for everyone there may yet be problems
in production that delay roll out of one
or more vaccines
but there is increasing optimism that
the virus can be defeated
thomas more sky news